[Musica]
[Applauso]
quando parlo con qualcuno per la prima
volta a un certo punto della
conversazione arriva la fatidica domanda
che cosa fai nella vita faccio ricerca
rispondo e il volto del malcapitato
interlocutore o interlocutrice che di
solito si aspetta che io faccia ricerca
in ambito scientifico o tecnologico
si paralizza in un'espressione fra
l'interessato e lo scettico quando
specifico che mi occupo di studi
danteschi di solito
seguono due domande
la prima conosci tutta la commedia
memoria e la seconda perché proprio
dante beh vi assicuro che non conosco la
commedia a memoria e perché dante perché
ho avuto la grande fortuna di incontrare
dei maestri e delle maestre che mi hanno
trasmesso la loro curiosità e la loro
passione per un autore e per un contesto
letterario e culturale estremamente
eterogeneo e vivace e soprattutto mi
hanno fornito gli strumenti critici per
comprenderlo e indagarlo a mia volta
primo al titolo dalla selva alla candida
rosa il paesaggio di dante questa sera
cercherò di percorrere con voi alcune
tappe dello straordinario viaggio
dantesco
soffermandomi su alcuni dei luoghi che
dante attraversa e sul valore degli
elementi naturalistici che chi li
compongono il paesaggio nella commedia
di dante non è un ornamento è una
semplice cornice entro cui inquadrare la
narrazione molto spesso invece è
portatore di molteplici significati che
arricchiscono il senso profondo della
poesia dantesca che è una poesia
salvifica perché al pari del testo
biblico mira alla conversione e alla
redenzione dell'umanità
incominciamo dall inferno
anzi
incominciamo
dal noto incipit del poema
nel mezzo del cammin di nostra vita mi
ritrovai per una selva oscura che è la
diritta via era smarrita ai quanto a
dire qual era e cosa dura e st selva
selvaggia e aspra e forte che nel
pensier rinnova la paura il poema si
apre all'insegna del buio e della paura
il personaggio che dice io che il
narratore della storia e che coincide
con dante alighieri di firenze sia
smarrito in una selva tetra impervia in
teak intricata il suo smarrimento e
anche il nostro
l'identificazione fra lui e noi lettori
è fulminea è indispensabile nel mezzo
del cammin di nostra vita
beh la selva la interpretiamo in prima
battuta in senso letterale ce le
immaginiamo esattamente così come ci
viene descritta eppure anche altro è un
simbolo ed è costruito su una fittissima
trama di richiami biblici e classici la
selva e il regno del vizio e dell'errore
e tutto ciò che allontana l'essere umano
dal vero bene che nel mondo di dante
naturalmente è il dio cristiano la selva
il regno della violenza della ferinità
del caos allo stato puro ed è tutto ciò
che si sa che si oppone alla civiltà e
alla vita fondata sul benessere comune
ma fortunatamente dante viene soccorso
la divinità gli concede di attraversare
i tre regni oltre mondani e lungo i
primi due e scortato da una guida molto
speciale virgilio questo è l'unico
viaggio che gli può affrontare per
salvarsi
la storia è nota i due scendono lungo la
voragine infernale incontrano diavoli
mostri dannati da gli ignavi alle anime
più nere e attraversano luoghi ostili e
pericolosi la foresta sinistra dei
suicidi il deserto infuocato dei
sodomiti e così conoscono e conosciamo
noi insieme a loro tutte le declinazioni
del male fino a giungere all'origine del
male lucifero conficcato al centro delle
acque ghiacciate di coach eto'o il fondo
dell'inferno e freddo e il gelo
dell'anima del cuore
i due si destreggiano in un'arrampicata
un po spericolata lungo il corpo di
lucifero attraverso nel centro della
terra percorrono un cunicolo stretto per
poi approdare sulla spiaggia del
purgatorio il purgatorio la montagna
altissima e ripida che si trova
nell'emisfero sud in mezzo all'oceano e
si è formata secondo dante proprio
quando lucifora è precipitato giù dal
cielo
precipitando l'angelo ribelle ha
prodotto uno stravolgimento cosmico che
ha cambiato gli assetti del globo
terracqueo
e così è nata la montagna purgatoriale e
si trova agli antipodi di gerusalemme e
quindi dalla parte completamente opposta
rispetto alla selva e rispetto
all'ingresso dell'inferno è
completamente opposta è l'atmosfera che
accoglie i due visitatori
il primo canto del purgatorio si apre
all'insegna di un atmosfera serena
rarefatta luminosa
sta per albeggiare
il cielo è blu come uno zaffiro
orientale dolce color d'orient al
zaffiro il pianeta venere illumina il
cielo orientale come il sorriso illumina
il volto di una persona
lo bel pianeta che da mar conforta
faceva tutto reader l'oriente a sud
invece splendono 4 stelle che nessuno
aveva mai visto fuor cala prima gente
cioè adamo ed eva beh anche questo
paesaggio lo interpretiamo dal punto di
vista letterale
eppure ha un forte valore spirituale e
penitenziale la luce il più potente
simbolo di salvezza indica la grazia
divina la speranza ritrovata il
risveglio tradizionalmente le quattro
stelle vengono interpretate come le
quattro virtù cardinali
prudenza giustizia fortezza temperanza
che vi aveva infuso nell'anima dei
progenitori dell'umanità
esse rappresentano la natura umana nella
sua condizione di innocenza originaria
inoltre l'accostamento fra il cielo e lo
zaffiro orientale non ha una funzione
decorativa nei lapidari medievali lo
zaffiro era simbolo di purezza di
castità dell'altezza della speranza
celeste
in effetti gli studiosi quando
interpretano il primo canto del
purgatorio parlano di paesaggio
liturgico perché gli elementi che lo
compongono come la luce lo splendore di
venere ritornano in lodi imi salmi che
venivano intonati in precisi momenti
della liturgia cristiana anche nel
periodo pasquale
e in effetti se consideriamo la
cronologia fittizia del viaggio
oltremondano l'alba qui descritta è
quella del mattino di pasqua del 1300
dante virgilio proseguono il viaggio
salgono il monte purgatoriale di cornice
in cornice
e arrivano a un'altra foresta è la
foresta del paradiso terrestre che è
collocato in cima al monte del
purgatorio
la foresta edenica che è paragonata alla
pineta di classe presso ravenna è folta
profumata riccamente fiorita al dolce
canto degli uccelli si accompagna il
suono delle fronde degli alberi mosse da
un'aura lieve sempre uguale a se stessa
se viene descritta con tutte le
caratteristiche del locus amoenus di
ascendenza classica e virgiliana la
foresta edenica trascende i modelli
classici infatti tutti i fenomeni
naturali
meteorologici hanno un'origine celeste
dipendono dalla mente divina la foresta
del paradiso terrestre completamente
diversa dalla selva infernale è divina
evviva
l'eden è il simbolo della felicità che
l'essere umano può raggiungere nella
vita terrena ed è prefigurazione della
beatitudine paradisiaca
il paesaggio ed è nico
fa da sfondo all'avvenimento più
importante del poema il pentimento di
dante incalzato dai durissimi rimproveri
di beatrice che proprio qui fa la sua
comparsa e sostituisce virgilio
pentito il pellegrino può completare il
viaggio
attraversa i nove ceri dell'acqua della
cosmologia medievale e raggiunge
l'empireo sede di dio e di tutti i beati
ma che ruolo ha la natura nel paradiso
beh prima di tutto il paradiso di dante
non è un giardino come vorrebbe
l'etimologia del termine ma è un luogo
di luce gli elementi naturali e floreali
che sono presenti anche nella terza
cantica né ricchissima assume una
valenza simbolica metaforica e mistica e
servono a descrivere una realtà
altrimenti inconoscibile per
l'intelletto umano
ad esempio l'empireo inizialmente si
rivela agli occhi di dante come un fiume
di luce che scorre fra due rive fiorite
e vidi lume in forma di rivera fulvi do
di fulgore in tra due rive dipinte di
mirabili primavera di tal fiumana o
sheehan faville vive ed ogni parte si
mette nei fiori quasi rubin che oro
circoscrive poche terzine dopo beatrice
spiega danti a noi lettori che il fiume
e i fiori sono solo una prefigurazione
della realtà celeste poco a poco dante
riuscirà a contemplare la realtà
paradisiache in tutta la sua verità
infatti una volta che è riuscita a
potenziare la propria vista il fiume
assume una forma circolare e i fiori non
sono altro che i beati che sono opposti
in innumerevoli seggi che attorniano la
circonferenza di luce e vi si specchiano
come in un lago le faville invece sono
gli angeli che volano facendo la spola
come delle api fra la luce divina e i
beati e così l'umanità beata può essere
descritta come una candela rosa
sempiterna informa dunque di candida
rosa mi si mostrava la milizia santa che
nel suo sangue cristo fece sposa e non è
un caso che nel poema proprio maria
venga definita rosa
perché secondo la dottrina cristiana
l'incarnazione la redenzione è potuta
venire proprio grazie alla vergine
qui vi è la rosa in che il verbo divino
carne si fece
e così nel solco delle immagini
naturalistiche che costellano la
commedia abbiamo percorso il cammino
poetico che dante ha predisposto per noi
e ci siamo resi conto di quanto la
natura il paesaggio siano parte
integrante del messaggio salvifico che
il poema vuole veicolare
dante scrive la commedia imprò del mondo
che mal vive e forse questa è una delle
idee cardine che possiamo fare ancora
nostre oggi la poesia può salvare sia
chi la scrive sia chi la legge e noi la
commedia la leggiamo ancora dopo 700
anni la parola di dante ha una forza
irresistibile
e capace di plasmare una realtà
fantastica e tangibile è semplicemente
ci trascina dentro e gli elementi
naturalistici floreali che abbiamo visto
questa sera certo d'interpretare sulla
base del contesto medievale da cui
scaturiscono beh ci parlano ancora e ci
fanno toccare con mano delle profondità
intellettuali spirituali ed emotive
davvero universali
[Applauso]